[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we want
to tell you about more covid 19 clusters
spreading in colleges all across the u.s
michigan state cancelled in-person
learning for the fall semester that was
only yesterday
and our league national correspondent
david begna reports that classrooms at
notre dame are also closed at least for
now
david good morning a lot going on here
good morning tony it seems like every
day this week we've heard about another
university somewhere in the country
that has an outbreak of clusters on
campus and more and more
universities universities are deciding
to roll back their reopening of
in-person classes
the spike in cases is very serious and
we must take serious steps to address it
this is the president of notre dame
university reverend john jenkins
he says he's prepared to make any
changes necessary he's moving classes
online for the next two weeks after a
surge in cases
147 since the campus opened on august
the 3rd
most are linked to an off-campus party
if these steps are not successful
we will have to send students home as we
did last spring
u.s coronavirus task force coordinator
dr debra burks
we can't have these large parties
because of the level of asymptomatic
spread
but that's what happened at michigan
state where more than a hundred students
were infected
yesterday the school's president seeing
outbreaks around the rest of the country
announced all classes will be remote
this fall
we got our senior year taken away and
then
now we don't even have a freshman year
incoming freshman annelise maxoud was
dorm shopping with her roommates when
she heard the news
she was planning to move to campus in
eight days i wish they would have told
us
earlier because then i wouldn't have had
all this time building up
this excitement for this experience that
i'm not going to get to have
on tuesday dr anthony fauci said the u.s
needs a strong attack
and uniform leadership against the virus
to return to some semblance of normalcy
i think a consistent message you know
from above would really be a very
very important factor in getting to
where we want to be
all week we've been following what's
happening at the university of north
carolina chapel hill they had four
clusters of cases
they decided to cancel in-person classes
move to remote learning
and yesterday anthony they told just
about all the students on campus if you
can go home
pack up your stuff and start heading
home tough choice for those kids
david thank you